okay welcome everybody
the two today's infrastructure meeting
I'm going to start with apologies I have
one from councilor kit can I have
someone move their place move Leslie
seconded Grant put the motion all those
in favor all right
we have no Declarations of Interest
being recorded to me and there is no
public forum and that takes us on to the
minutes of the March 7 infrastructure
meeting
can I have someone move that they are
true and correct thank you Trish
seconded Alex put that all those in
favor
aye and against this carried takes us
now to a solid waste update item five
Peter do you want to speak to that come
on
so um
as as per the previous updates well can
you just grab the microwave
as per previous updates trying to keep
the reports consistent for familiarity
um we can see that the waste of the
landfill is uh dropping over time
and we can also see that the recycling
is um going up which which is obviously
good the recycling has popped up a
little bit in February because we had
increased tonnages come coming in
compared to the previous month
there's a
anybody has any questions in regard to
the data and the
graphs
okay
um I opened before anyone questions
regarding
yes Ria
um thank you um Peter just wanted just
over your last comment that
um the weather has
um provided
an increase
not not the weather
um there's an increase in in tonnages
coming through
so there was an increase in recycling
compared to the previous month
so in warmer temperatures
the site recycling increases is that
what you say
um sorry we haven't formed a correlation
with the the weather
temperature then you use the word
temperature
no sorry I must be hearing things sorry
I think there was a it may have been
there was a word there around the trend
the downward trend
s right that's okay
just yeah yes yeah thanks chair just in
terms of your
um School sustainability Network can you
give it a little bit more detail around
you know how much of that's happening
and um
you know what how that's being monitored
around impact and things like that sure
so the school system building Network
comes from the uh the the
um the trust sustainability trust and
it's a train the trainer where they can
come in and they teach the teachers now
they've been looking for a facility in
invercargill that we can com we can
provide to them to organize so we found
somewhere and they'll be providing
um education locally at free of charge
uh now looking at it how it represents
and how it's worked throughout the rest
of the country we've not looked at that
right so so secondary um what what
because my perspective is probably I
think that's a great way that we get a
change in Behavior around how we look
and treat you know all sorts of way
Spirit recycling or actual waste
what I'm interested in is what sort of
monitoring
is happening or proposed to happen
around that change that we might see as
a as a result of an investment sure
um that we we don't have any um insights
into that at the moment
but we would like to see that the
schools would start to report their
improvements through through those
without initiatives so is the trust
if they stipulated that to the schools
about how they will monitor the program
and report back on effectiveness
I haven't looked into that
but it's free of charge and and it's a
good way forward into it
thank you Trish
is there any consideration given to the
communication team doing something about
a campaign
in the schools
I mean seriously if you're going to
educate them and it's free of charge and
it's outside school ads and you know
whatever
really needs to be a focus
and if the council is making a serious
consideration to reducing something it
may well be that's something that could
be done across the city you know some
kind of
culture or something something in the
schools to encourage schools and kids to
minimalize I don't know it just seemed
to me the next step sure so we we've put
the community the communications or the
educational strategy together we're just
building the budget for that yeah and
we'll be presenting it to the uh waste
Advisory Group always net to accept it
for it to be rolled out
okay I think um
right I've got Darren next
year
not a bad suggestion because it used to
be when recycling started off that the
education program went into
kindergartens and schools and that's how
they got parents to make that uh that
cultural change I guess one of the
things that we need to be
cognizant of is people's understanding
of the phone difference between
minimization and recycling because they
don't know nor are they that invested in
in either
um and if we start to ER back towards
recycling then we'll fall into that
Nationwide campaign that's on at the
moment of what's happening to stuff
that's been put in the recycle bin and
to most of it's going to landfill why do
we bother well because it's a good habit
for when the markets open up
but that said
while there was the education program
for recycling that went and it would be
interesting to get that report on on the
minimization aim aimed at kids because
it was a useful tool
Evelyn then Alex
so I noticed that the program that
you're referred to but I know also
noticed the absence of any comment about
parakori and noting that
um there is already reaching into a lot
of things at places like guangario and
El Mirai so are they have they been
approachable if they approached you to
work with you and if they have why are
they not mentioned in this sorry
um yes they are have been approached and
we've asked the important metrics for
the improvements they've made not
inclusion in the reporters and oversight
thank you Alex
um thank you chair um I I'm just more of
an expansion on what Darren had
mentioned was the um education programs
that went out from waste net
um and well the way wag group and waste
net um from was that around
2021 onwards I believe and there was
quite an emphasis on schools in kohanga
and kindergartens and the waste free
wander program so
um that I remember it because my
daughter ended up bringing some
resources home and they were um the
likes of the careers Fest and stuff like
that and just getting out there in the
community to help the community and also
all young people understand the
difference between minimization and
recycling as well they also equipped
um teachers in schools with teaching
resources for the same sort of the same
sort of campaigns and stuff like that so
I do remember seeing around quite a lot
I think it's just really important that
we keep that momentum going and rebooted
a bit I think to your point Council of
oil be really good to have a report and
understand what
exactly we're doing in that space
right like I've got a question regarding
that um
the reporting back with a recycling
education strategy you said you're going
to bring it back to wastenet Now
wastenet does not have a recycling
contract that contractors with ICC
um so wouldn't it be better coming back
here
rather than wasting it
um it was around waste minimization
strategy Mr chair okay it's around
memorization okay so my question now
changes to education obviously we've the
Glass Project is is has to follow our
long-term plan process so in the
meantime it's been suggested by quite a
few counselors and and our communication
team that we
actually get out to the public adults
mainly and educate them on proper
recycling habits and that even as simple
as washing out your bottles you know the
ones you are going to put in the
recycling bin tomato sauce whatever
clean them out mug bottles clean them
out take the top stuff like that
um what real simple one it's pretty hard
to determine what plastic is a one two
three four five six or seven unless
you've got good eyesight
but um are we going to win how far away
is that and and US sort of cleaning up
our act with recycling because the bins
that are arriving the stuff that's
arriving at recycled South are pretty
scruffy it's it's pretty horrible stuff
so we've we've we've broken the um the
waste minimization uh education strategy
down into uh schools uh residential and
Commercial and as part of that waste
minimization we'll also be focusing on
the recycling
um uh message to them
uh how far away is it it's uh we are as
we are actually engaged in in this in
the schools obviously
um in relation to adults we need to put
that action in our plan into action as
our help how soon we're talking a month
two months three months
um I I would say for the new Financial
year
and what sort of budget are we
allocating because obviously we want to
we want to really get out there I mean
what we're dealing with is
an instruction guide put on the inside
of a lid that was delivered in 2010 now
we've moved on a bit since then so I
think habits need to change and and it's
just a polite message of letting people
know so
yeah yeah certainly
thank you chair
um I think I just want to probably give
some greater context to where we're
currently sitting nationally in this
space
um I absolutely agree with the comments
that have been made around us wanting to
get out really clear messaging around
um Recycling and waste minimization more
generally and particularly that message
around what is actually good recycling
versus and what tends to be called in
the industry is wish cycling where you
Chuck it in there and hope that it might
be recyclable
um what's been happening though in this
space nationally is that central
government has been looking at
standardizing what is collected by
councils in recycling nationally and
they came out last week and made some
announcements about that we've been a
little bit hesitant to go out and push
hard on the recycling message until we
got Clarity around what that message
would be going forward because we didn't
want to go hard at a campaign pain for
six months and then suddenly find whoops
the directions changed we're actually
collecting a completely different
um quantity of items going forward so
now that we have that direction around
actually what should be collected by
councils nationally and we actually have
to standardize that by early next year
um well but we can straight away kick
into gear that messaging around what
good recycling looks like going forward
something that I've been very keen to do
since I've been down here as we are I
agree behind the eight ball in that
space so so the budget for that would
come from this committee because we like
we do need a budget we're not talking a
couple hundred dollars here uh no the um
so although invercargill city council
holds the direct contract for recycling
waste education still sits within the
Ambit of waste net and comes out of the
joint budget of waste net
okay so that's great because obviously
uh wasting it accumulates a fund gets
ten dollars or may have moved to 15 but
at least ten dollars for a return that
goes to the landfill so over the last um
three years I'm not sure that their
plan's been tapped into
um there there is a wasting it has
significant funds to be able to use in
this space yeah okay right significant
it sounds like a big number so that's
good we won't worry about the budget
okay Peter I think that's all questions
no thank you very much Peter
moves on to item six which is Bluff
Wastewater Community recommendations oh
sorry sorry sorry well done yeah yeah
yeah
recommendations are that we received the
report so that which is the solid waste
update we also note the data's for both
Recycling and waste of landfill can I
have someone move those please
move down second Tom and put those
motions all those in favor
that's Carrie it takes us now tap six
which is bluffway's water consent
renewal
and
and Aaron is speaking to that
thank you chair
uh this is a little bit of a a different
report to come to infrastructure
committee as we do tend to keep
um operational
um reports out of this space it is
something that is very much in the
operational sphere
um however we thought this one was an
important one because it does I guess
speak to the risk profile that we hold
as Council and it is a significant piece
of work for us to undertake
um what's particularly key around this
one is that there's movement nationally
around what can and can't be done in
terms of Wastewater consents moving
forward and whether it is appropriate
for us to continue to discharge to
water-based environments so that's going
to be a key element as we move through
this process
um we want to be really sure that we
start back with all of our stakeholders
right at the start we don't want to be
going into this with any pre-formed
solutions or ideas on what the new
consent may look like
and so that's why you'll see that
there's quite an extensive working group
that has been proposed to work through
this process with us over the coming
years
I would just note that this process does
transition over that current timetable
that we have for the new three Waters
entity but we need to commence the
process before the new entity is in
place otherwise we'd simply be left with
insufficient time for The Entity to get
a consent in place and I apologize that
we did find after the fact that there is
a comment around the under three Waters
reforms on page three where we talk
about the new entity starting on one
July 2023 I apologize I don't know
anything new it should be one July 2024
in that space
happy to take any questions thank you
Erin questions
thanks Aaron just with respect to the
people on the
work group at Bluff community board
member was a given consideration for
someone to have you know be an observer
on that board given it's a pretty
important project for the bluff
community
uh so in terms of the working group we
have got down there a member of the
bluff community board yes
on the list on page four
um well I'm sorry as sorry as sorry as
under key stakeholders sorry my
apologies
um that's an oversight it should be
there thank you yeah yeah cheers
okay I got Evelyn then Tom so an actual
fact that's partly my concern has been
dealt with because I did notice the
absence of a community board member
um but I did notice the council ideally
naita representative employee in
Brackets and that sort of puzzled me as
well so um but that's okay more of us
that are there the better but
I didn't know that we defined staff
members in that way
uh look it's one that we're um look
invercargill city hasn't done a consent
in this space um of this type for quite
a while
um which means that we've gone out and
we've spoken to our peers around what's
worked well for them what advice they've
had from um the planners that they've
engaged
um what they've spoken about is that as
in addition to having the elected
members
um and external Representatives that are
you know I guess speaking from a
monofinoa perspective
um that it was also beneficial to them
when they were able to have
um essentially a staff representative
who was an ewe member
um really that distinction that the team
had put forward was essentially saying
it would be preferable if that was
somebody from a South Island naitahu
perspective as opposed to more Broad
don't
actually Evelyn just said exactly what I
was going to say I mean I I just simply
me on that line that is inappropriate to
Define her ethnicity as part of your job
description it may even be illegal I
suspect so I mean I I think that could
be bad wanted to be honest
I I mean understand why you're going to
do it and what the outcome is going to
be but wanting it that way seem to me to
be inappropriate
and the wording would that be the best
way forward I'm comfortable I just I
just need to think about it a little bit
myself so okay thank you Mr Mayor
and yeah I'd actually delete that whole
that whole section that says a council
represented because I mean you want
something that's got some experience in
the in the three Waters area you just
don't want to go out and get a staffing
if somebody comes from from the bluff
community and wants to talk to somebody
with an emu base they've got monophenol
representatives there they've got tal
marimar Representatives as well I mean
how many more do you need to have it
seems that this this group's got about
eight or nine
um invercargill staff members on it
already
um it's heavily stacked in that favor
um so I just wouldn't have that I think
it's a
it's not an appropriate representation
to make to go looking for somebody
that's
naito
Darren
to be fair
if we're submitting to environment South
and why would we ask him to be a
stakeholder
because they've got a they're the
decision maker at the other end
uh that's more around making sure that
we are bringing them on the journey
through the process of timelines what
they expect to see where and that we are
ticking all of the boxes as we move
through their process so that's staff
advice yeah thank you yes absolutely
staff advice
okay any further questions or comments
in that case
um we have some recommendations yeah
we received the report
we note the uh consent renewal process
be started there's part of the attached
program and we note that the internet
approach group reformed
and consultant RFP be crafted people
move that way uh moved Leslie seconded
fresh
I'm gonna put that motion alone is in
favor against that is Carrie thank you
it takes us on to
transport procurement strategy the
national land transport activities
Russell
welcome
good afternoon
this paper really is I guess a follow-on
from
a draft procurement strategy which was
brought to I think the December meeting
it's one of our key strategies that we
actually need to have with tahi because
it's the piece that actually entitles us
to start to be able to claim subsidy
during that process we have worked with
wakite through a number of I guess
relatively minor issues that of the
draft strategy had
attached in the report is the letter of
endorsement from them
I believe that it Reliance pretty well
with their council's procurement
strategy anyway and I think it's the
area where we've actually had to have
some work on is the broader outcomes and
in the paper it actually looks to
highlight where we will be going
with all procurement it really becomes
making sure we get value for money and
we actually have a fair and reasonable
process that the uh I guess the market
can actually see us and I think our
strategy will align with that in Council
so I'm happy to receive questions right
I'm going to open the floor for
questions
foreign
do you think that the uh
current
income source for Rocket katahi is
enough using radius charges and fuel
exercise taxes
it's a really interesting question I
guess it's not necessarily sits inside
this place however but it is a
hypothecated fund as such so all the
money that's actually generated from
Road user decks and and those sources
are put straight to routing so it
doesn't necessarily get lost for the
wrong words but the right intention but
I'm actually asking where would more
come from because obviously it's my
opinion that that as that is not enough
there's still ongoing work through
wakutahi and and the Ministry of
Transport to look at a range of I guess
options across the country where more
Revenue will come from and
know that in the past they've talked of
things like Road tolling and places
depending on on where you are and what
you're doing so some of the um major
projects I've looked at some of those
things but that is still a challenge
that we face
oh I've got the mayor and there was
just to add to that discussion um
recently the me is or some years had a
meeting with waikato in Wellington
and one of the issues that's come up
that's now been um
promoted by the national party is one of
their policies is that e-cars don't
contribute
certainly a vehicle doesn't pay any
excise tax on on fuel and nor does it
claim that needs any mileage that you'd
have on diesels so that was interesting
and
wakakatai did say that they've got a
funding shortfall because last year a
third of all new cars coming into the
country were ecats so they have some
funding issues so you're quite right to
raise that and the other issue is the
National Party are saying that they
would scrap excise
tax on fuel and the uh kilometer rates
on diesel and they'd have a a kilometer
rate that goes across all vehicles
depending on the different classes of
vehicles so that would force
ecast to come into the equation and pay
for the upkeeper wrote
which I thought was interesting yeah
thanks for that I did some research last
night because I immediately sort of
thought this is not fair but I read that
mid next year 2024
um EVS will be paying Road user charges
yeah and the other one was when I read
about the hydrogen you know being
implemented as a dual fuel and I thought
oh that's a good way to escape
fuel tax but no
um I read that uh
Vehicles over 3.5 tons have to pay Road
user charges regardless of whether
they're paired by a sale or nuclear or
whatever yeah
right any further questions comments
no in that case
um we're gonna move the recommendations
which are we received the report and
this committee recommends to council to
adopt the invercargill city council
transport procurement strategy Financial
assisted land transport activities for
the next three years or sorry for 2022
to 2025
can I have someone move that please
moved rear seconded Tom I'll put that
motion all those in favor against that
is Carrie
thank you for that Russell but you may
remain seated
for the Anzac Day road closures so
thanks Mr Chu this is um part of our
procedural
process that we need to follow when we
temporarily close a road for an event
um
um obviously Anzac days are relatively
important day for the community but also
the impact on our network is exceedingly
minor with both just short sections of
Victoria Avenue and Gala Street being
impacted so just like to place the
recommendations in front of you happy to
receive questions moved sorry yeah thank
you sorry
um I'd just like to make an addition to
that one in that we've had some
developments in the space around public
events that I'd just like to ask Andrew
Cameron to come up and speak to as it
may impact our approval of this
recommendation and require an amendment
welcome Andrew and grab the microphone
thank you
um look I suppose it's part of uh
the focus that we're putting on health
and safety and sort of understanding our
role and in this sort of circumstance
and in other circumstances around
Council
where we allow functions or events
whatever you want to call it to use
Council land or facilities or in this
case a road which we otherwise control
there is an expectation or an
understanding that there's a joint
responsibility between the what they
call the the CBU under the act and so we
just because we've closed the road or or
given a piece of land to an event
doesn't mean we're totally absorbed of
our health and safety obligations and so
what we're looking at doing is not
necessarily
it's more so you understand as part of
our process going forward we'll be
asking for them those event holders to
show us what their workplace health and
safety plan is to ensure that if
anything occurs we've made sure they've
got one in place and that we've
they're doing what we would otherwise be
expected to do if we're having the event
there ourselves and so that's really the
The Tweak that we're looking at bringing
in place here
um Grant then Evelyn and then Tom it
just respect to this closure so
um having attended the event for a
number of years
um a lot of people come down from the
old Museum and across the road on um
it's still Kelvin Street I think isn't
it but it's it's
you know the traffic's still coming
through from Calvin street trying to get
through
to this sort of Kevin Street and so have
you looked at actually closing Calvin
Street further down Calvin Street
towards sorry can I just start I might
just speak to that I just want to be
got I guess two two elements of health
and safety that we're speaking about one
is around the traffic management
component which Russell and his team are
quite used to reviewing and bringing up
the other pieces around the health and
safety of the actual event management
side of things and that's where as part
of our traffic management process we
haven't historically required event
organizers to provide us with a health
and safety record or a health and safety
plan for their event and where this has
come up in the last week is there has
been some case law where councils have
found themselves in trouble for not
um doing due diligence around the health
and safety of the event itself being
held on Council land yeah so I
understand that there was my point my
point was are we going far enough for
the road closure because you know I've
seen it often that a car will be coming
through the apostle Germany and those
little kids sort of throwing and frying
around there and I just think it'll be
safer if we actually closed Kelvin
Street
so stopped cars coming through there for
the period of time because it yeah it's
a busy time so Mr chair we respond to
what the uh against the Trevor
management planner has appeared in terms
of that we can
um there's no no real problem of
allowing greater but that it's never
been requested by that by the event
organizer and I guess we typically are
looking at responding to what they're
looking for
um my understanding is also they have
they're well marshaled and there's lots
of people around so
we haven't seen any issue that would
actually give us any real concern that
would but all the areas where people are
walking towards them
um people need to take their due care
and it is typically during darkness that
yeah yeah
okay Evelyn
um yes I was just interested that it was
only
for invercargill that the closure and I
wondered with the greater attendance at
local
um
Anzac Day events whether there are
starting to become traffic management
issues at other locations and the reason
I raise it is because I've been at the
one at Bluff a couple of times and I
have been really concerned at how close
people are to the roadway how close the
traffic is and yet we don't seem to have
an indication that they
thank you is it a lack of awareness that
people can ask for this kind of
um
process to take place in there for their
particular event or is it just that in
the past they've been big enough to
Warrant it
I think the bluff one's relatively
straightforward that it's um a road
that's managed by wakatai so it's really
it's really to them they need to address
that issue I think most of most event
organizers have now
um hidden directions with Council over
the the regular events and they know
that they need to come and have a
conversation with us about how their
event will run and I guess that sort of
ties into where Andrew was going is that
the safety plan is actually them
explaining what they're doing so we have
confidence that we know so
um
I think most of the events will know
that they want so um and depends on how
much rooms around around the feature
like um
as well
um Tom I've got you Nix are you
yeah yeah thank you I mean obviously I
support the recommendation but uh I mean
I was interested in Andrew's comments
about some new circumstances was that
the Thames District Council
case with a rubber slide
yeah and I was keen and involved in the
fringes of that and and you know there
were multiple feelings in fact in a part
of the district council that led to them
being convicted of um so it's not just a
matter of I mean I think if you do right
you're saying I just don't think we
should allow that to scare us off
from doing stuff but if you are
organizing something you've got to make
sure that you're doing the appropriate
checks and they had not
we are peer reviewing the plan no we're
not we have to endorse it accept it or
just look at it and this is this is sort
of the Tom's point you you don't want to
make this uh
a job for Council because it's not
council's job but Council has a pcbu has
a uh a level of responsibility
and so an understanding that the
organizing entity has considered these
issues
will in the ordinary circumstance be
sufficient if if they say yes we've
considered you these issues here's a
piece of paper that says we will be safe
you might say
that doesn't answer my question but if
they give you something that stored out
it's been that's that's the extent
you're not taking ownership of it but
you are ensuring that they've considered
the issues which is consistent with your
level of responsibility
okay thanks so we've got knobby Ria and
then Darren
um so
it would be helpful at some stage to
have a paper on this I feel
if you think about some recent events
um if we were to allow some sort of
event in this street where we can put
the bollards up do we need a health and
safety plan
the bluff Hill Racing incident recently
with uh Burton Monroe the recent George
B event out at territory which is
Council owned land
uh where do we stop start on this and if
we're thinking about Anzac parade does
that mean we need to cite the health and
safety Plan before we approve the
closure of the road
or are we doing it afterwards and where
will our liability be if we do it
afterwards and it's not service Factory
and it's not a simple question for me I
know obviously because we one of the
recommendation three is we
approved the road closure yeah foreign
I think
part of what we're using is the
legislation to actually formally stop
the road well so formally have the sorry
have a temporary closure so I guess that
to me there's one part of that there's
also part of good practice from Council
actually making sure we know how to run
the event and I think you could keep
those isolated because you still could
have the road being able to be
temporarily closed subject to a
a planned appropriate plan being
received by Council
do you want to alter recommendation
three
hey I'm happy happy to do so
right okay
what what wording would you like to add
I would suggest you say subject to
receiving an appropriate you know
receiving a safety plan for the event
through you and Mr chair yes we've got
uh Ria you're next can I um a couple
comments really
um recent I don't know if this is the
appropriate place to put this but you'll
tell me yes or no so just recently
weatherproof funding for this event to
go ahead and inside of that funding plan
uh I feel that there was a health on
health and safety it risk analysis
inside of that came to our committee so
I'm wondering what's changed from
theater last week to today apart from
the recent um commentary that that Aaron
provided to us another thing is that
we've had the city to Sue from just
recently
we've heard is the messiest various
events held on Council land that is
beholding office as a pcub to see all of
these plans prior to any of those dates
been confirmed and also running through
the timeline of what I expect to come
here as
recommendations to the council so that
we've done our homework it might be
easiest
if you rather accept the main suggestion
we have a paper later or if you want to
have a bit of a discussion on this in
public excluded might be a better place
to have some of this conversation
um so that you can understand some of
the drivers
more fully
so you recommended we have that
discussion public escalated or take the
Mayors I'm comfortable either way but I
think either of those would be okay I'm
just gonna find useful okay I'm just
going to park that rear if we can I'm
going to go for Darren and then Leslie
so I can see the good rationale for
the addition to recommendation three
I guess partially it's a heads up that
we may be approached by some people who
give us that feedback of our council's
asking us this additional question now
we've never had to do that in the past
so that you have an understanding of why
we've got to go back I don't know that I
need an additional paper
I think I I understand the reason why we
need to be asking the question of event
organizers because we are shared pcbus
Mr chair I guess my going forward will
seek this information at the time that
they apply to us so as our paper brings
it forward we'll we'll be bringing that
comment that will have received that
prior to prior to asking
and at that point if they've done the
work and they've met the requirements
the question is answered okay Leslie
then Tom
Mr chair I
understand that
a slight prop
that it is now the 4th of April and this
event takes place on the 25th of April
and has taken place on the 25th of April
or more years than I have been alive
um and it is a little late in the piece
to be putting this requirement in for
this particular time
I think we we have the evidence here
that they have already arranged
Marshalls we know that we are going to
have put in place the closure of the
roads and the signs and Road cones that
we have always had in place I just think
that it may be a little bit
more than we should do on the 4th of
April to a volunteer group who has run
an event for many years to now tell them
what that we expect them to produce an
appropriate health and safety plan when
we when we know that for many years they
have had
various planning on Pace and they have
always made sure that they have a
reasonable number of people keeping an
eye on what is going on it's just but
through YouTube don't they already have
one that that may be what we discovered
well I would like to think we did I'm
just a little bit worried about actually
putting it in in quite that directive
wording at the Slate
okay
um Michael
throw yourself chair
um the council is quite right in
relation to this particular event
because we've because we're providing
funding we've already
um I we've already cited the safety plan
in relation to that because we do it
through our funding process
um you would add this to any other road
closure process that we don't provide
funding from that perspective that we
would have had to have cited as part of
that process so you could remove that
and we would just amend that from our
processes going forward so that would be
added to it in any other road closure
application coming forward
so we get rid of the red stuff
yeah thanks for raising that Ria thank
you
thank you
um thank you Michael who was next Tom
I think the report that's required is
not about this I think it's um more
General
um a question about a council's
liability with respect to events so I
think we you know we should ask for a
report in respect to that because it is
unfortunately you know done I think you
use the word receive assurances actually
if you look at the Thames District case
you know that you know that you're
expected to go and check right it's not
just somebody to receiving assurances
um so I think it important that would be
very helpful to you absolutely this is
uh playing with the big boys when this
goes wrong so
um
sorry chair is is that we that staff
have checked yeah yeah it's not that
each one of us has to go around and
check the big rubber sliders yeah that's
right yeah it's got me thinking about
the center parade now
don't they're a nightmare
right okay look is everyone happy there
and I think that the the idea of getting
clarification about we were yeah yeah be
fantastic Okay so
we have three recommendations we
received a report
uh
resolve that it will not impede traffic
and reasonably and then item three is we
approve the closure for that specified
streets
um because I've moved Leslie seconded
Trish and put that emotional as a favor
all right that is against that's carried
thanks see you
um Andrew we don't
oh unless we're after some stuff for the
CCTV privacy no
okay Russell CCTV thanks Mr chair
um just to perhaps we're at a stage that
we've now completed our um I guess our
needs and our understanding of what CCTV
means across both the city center and
the in The Wider Community certainly has
a wider scope than when we started and I
guess that's really
um the project has just wanted to make
sure we could understand
um and not be limited necessarily in the
first instance
um it's around the city center
um the working group
that we've been have has strongly
endorsed that all regions um be
implemented I guess the timing of that
is I guess part of the opportunity of
where this report highlights it um
I do wish to point out and
recommendation and the recommendations
that in your report it had
recommendation seven but it should
actually be
c6c one and two to make any sense when
you when you come to consider the
recommendations and they are presented
in a manner that are trying to give you
some options which perhaps might be a
little bit confusing for a start off but
hopefully we'll be able to work through
that
yeah and I'm he's happy to receive any
questions
okay questions
yes you might be able to answer this
chair just just for the benefit of
public watching in so this
um this system will be set up and
governed by Council
um as opposed to being monitored by the
police no
what generally happens is that
um the Mainframe for the device would
say go in the library
um appropriate rooms there and access to
that would be whoever Council feels
appropriate to to obviously give to now
certain areas may need to be involved
just with traffic busyness you know we
we could actually use that because if
you look at the regions we could be
monitoring traffic trends that we're
unaware of sure
um but as far as the crime you know the
crime aspect goes I imagine
um that the police the Christchurch from
what I understand they would access it
they'd have a live stream yeah yeah that
they would have
um and if we go to
um NPR cameras which is number plate
recognition then they have the instant
ability of searching for number plates
or being notified by entering a number
plate into the system if that appears
in front of one of these cameras and a
notification alerts them straight away
so yeah
gee I think that the the moderate dots
would be as the equipment would be
stored in Council and owned by Council
and we would allow streaming to those
parties that are permitted to do under
our privacy policy
go there we go
right any other questions
just just one chair again just on the
issue of privacy which has always been a
contentious issue and I'm a strong
supporter of having these cameras but
but how far does the ability to use the
system go so for over so it could
um could the police look at the person
leaving a uh an alcoholic station that
was clearly drunk would it be an okay
process to use it and go and track the
person down and potentially have the uh
the owner of the facility uh
ask questions about why the person was
so drunk right I might get um angry's
probably there oh oh no chocolate
Russell first but you can always pass it
yeah we go short past Andrew
Russell sort of
Dodge the answer to the question when he
said it will depend on your privacy act
you and and this is the key part in this
from a privacy perspective council is
the owner of this information
it is you who determine who gets it and
how they get it
um once you pass it to that person you
have no control over what they do with
it but be clear and it's something that
you'll have to address later you don't
have to address for the purposes of
these resolutions
that the Privacy obligation rests with
Council
the police have made it quite clear the
ombres made it quite clear that once you
give it to the police you're
essentially fulfilled the Privacy Act
duty to ensure that they can have the
information
or whoever I mean police or whoever it
doesn't matter who you give it to
let's say just to lead on from that so
if if based on what cheers just told us
that that Christchurch police will have
a live stream of this all the time they
can be watching 24 7.
for a home take watching yesterday
um and if that's the case the fact that
we've given them a live stream 24 7
means we've given away our ability
to hold them accountable for what they
use it for and we are no longer liable
nope
is that what you're saying
what I'm saying is that you're liable
for any breach of privacy that occurs
with that information
so the the when you look at the
ombudsman's investigations into this
effectively what they've said is that
the police have no privacy obligation
because the entity who gave them the
well they do but simplistically the
entity that collected it has passed it
to the police and in passing it you're
doing the Privacy tests around whether
or not the collection's appropriate
whether or not the you says in who
you're giving into is appropriate and so
the police almost get it or whoever I
don't want to use it please all the time
whoever we give it to gets it with a bit
of a free pass
in that they've even collector so all
those sort of obligations that come with
collection don't fall on them they've
been given it on the understanding that
they were able to be given it under a
Privacy Act
so again going back to my original
scenario as an example just because I
want to I want to flesh out where our
liability now sits we have a live stream
of the police 24 7. they pick up
somebody stumbling out of a pub that's
clearly absolutely legless
um and the police pop on around to see
that person and the process talks to the
owner of the establishment about serving
alcohol to somebody who's clearly drunk
do we then get a complaint
I guess the answers yes no and there
have been examples of that so we can ask
Sarah yeah I'll let Darren speak now
because of his so police tried to
prosecute somebody who was quite wobbly
leaving a licensed establishment
claiming that they were intoxicated
where in fact they had a physical
disability yeah and they learned very
severe lesson so I guess what we have to
do is trust that the police are going to
and it's a big T on trust use it for the
resolving of Acts of crime and the NPR
system is what detects
vehicles that are associated with crime
sure I understand uh so if if somebody
was stumbling out of the langlands yeah
um not an issue but if they're having a
stabby experience quite an issue yeah
um
but what I was suggesting was that if
they were stumbling out of the language
would the police then talk to the
language familiar about it because it's
so subjective you can't prove that
there's intoxication involved in there
okay because as I say it could be a
physical disability
or they could have been having a seizure
and falling over you just don't know
okay right okay I'm going to rear and
then easily basically just speaking with
Darren saying you can't press conceive
of crime because of a person's movement
outside of building the information can
only be used and the request that was
made to us for which is determined a
crime after the effect as I understand
it but the crime could be that the owner
of the establishment
and it's clearly drunk it becomes a
different under different legislation
still a crime right Leslie
thanks Mr chair I was just going to
point out that um as part of the whole
project we are going to revise their
CCTV apology policy yeah fairly
profoundly
um it's written there on page four
um and in the revision of that existing
privacy policy
we would obviously be taking into
account all such matters because what we
are going to end up with is a policy we
intend
the public to have faith means that the
information is being used appropriately
and is held and managed appropriately so
we would obviously take into account
any of the applications have just been
talked about in updating that policy and
I think because the intention is as part
of this project to update our privacy
policy that we've got a conversation for
another day when that privacy policy
draft correct is presented to us and
then we could discuss hasn't taken into
account all the relevant matters We
Believe should be taken into account yes
no the policy is important and the
cameras are just a tall uh Grant yeah
and the other thing to remember we're
not break a nuke around here are we like
there's other cities with this fully in
place so
um you know I think we're just gonna
so when we got from the working group
which Liz and I were on we've had to
several workshops and a lot of
discussion
the importance was defining who who was
the most important I guess in the sense
because we were limited by budget
it's been an eight-year project as
you're aware so we couldn't determine
whether it's the city-centered people
were more important to Windsor or
Glengarry or Bluff or wherever to be
honest so then we trickled down to the
effect well we need to be proactive
around the widest city the state the
widest city obviously involving
everybody so it's obviously an increased
budget that was quite clear the police
were exceptionally supportive as were
all the volunteers involved and I know
there was some discussion from the
police around contribution some of you
have asked about that wasn't forthcoming
but after a long discussion
um we felt that everyone was as
important as each other and most
importantly for the South or for
invercargill that we promote ourselves
as being a very safe not just inner city
but city so we have a point of
difference from some other cities that
maybe not quite as safe so we understand
fully the cameras don't protect but only
one part of the toolbox
security without a shadow of a doubt so
that's where we sort of got to Leslie
didn't we in the end of the day um
much wider perspective yeah no that's a
good thing right I'm just going to take
one more which is Tom and then I'm we're
going to go through the there's a few
Wars to get sorted out here so yeah the
only question I have is that you know
that that argument can be taken to you
know you have a CCTV camera in every
street corner
and I think where we're talking about
privacy we're focused on privacy in
terms of what's your obligations to
um you know when we give away
information that we don't you know
compromise something but there's another
aspect of privacy which is that you know
a lot of people I think don't
particularly want themselves to be
watched everywhere they go
and there is a balance I think to be
struck between looking to provide
security in the appropriate places and
then the other side here you know that
that point that people shouldn't
actually be looked at every single step
they take everybody on the city and in
in my view and I and I don't know
whether we are really taking that any
account as we as we think about these I
mean I'm inclined to supporters I
totally agree with the policy I mean I'd
support you but I think I would see well
look let's no just end up the security
cameras everywhere behind every tree
like I said no more but
just a short comment Alex is short Alex
then Evelyn
um it's just a short comment and um
there's absolutely no doubt like um
Scout said that um invercargill was
touted to be a fantastic safe and safe
place I think it's reaching a little bit
far to say that we'll have cameras on
every single like post and city or
anything but um I hear you concern
um the
funny thing is though is that you're
right people don't want to be surveilled
wherever they go at the moment but they
already are you've got a cell phone in
your pocket that's linked to GPS systems
you've got Facebook algorithms that are
also you know like use your GPS system
everything that you use on social media
every time you swipe your if POS card or
use your afterpay or anything like that
that's tracking the fact that you've
been to liquorland the data world is you
know like it's a massive beast in this
day and age so actually us just
providing a visual link
um that affirms where we're already
tracking as around the city is just
another way that we're actually keeping
our citizens safe rather than you know
it's very scary right Evelyn and mine
was similar because I think that
the options that were being shown
show a wider view than just property I
think when we focus on only on property
then I'm not so engaged with this
conversation but with people
being safer our areas being safer
um
I want people to be able to walk around
this city whenever they want to walk
around this city or so those sorts of
things I think
you trade off don't you you trade off
that sense of nobody's watching me to
somebody is making sure that I can get
from A to B without being assaulted or
you know whatever and for me that's
important
but I do like the idea that you're going
to look at Bluff because I'm a bit
worried about Sterling Point
right okay we're going to receive uh
firstly received the report now we we
look at the four options
for paragraph two
and really to me option two or four are
the standouts now potentially they're
the same because if you do it in the
staged event
it's almost consecutive to what option b
or option two says
um so look can I just have someone move
which the preferred option and would
that come actually I'd like it to come
from either Leslie or Nigel um
okay and I'll second a bit thank you for
that
so discussion around that
before I put it to the boat option yes
Darren I would have preferred option
four because it provided a bit more
financial flexibility rather than the
more immediate impact on on the budgets
so the question becomes what are you
going to cut that was that was just I
guess my thought the flexibility but
it's up to any thought about that but it
leaves me in a conflicted space where
I'm not comfortable with it falling into
the next budget yeah as much as I would
be spreading it over two or three years
and yet I don't want to vote against it
because I want the system in Ira I like
I I reckon we give it a shot on Two And
and we've got to do something so right
now I'm going to move so it's been moved
and seconded I'm going to put that
motion for
number two
all those in favor aye all right okay
just gonna move on to
uh we're confirming the priority
progress City Center and then we go to
uh four
which notes
um no additional budget or
um B which
gives it a budget
so again recently and Nigel
okay let's see okay any discussion on
that I think everyone's agree and so
that so we'll put that all those in
favor all right okay so the move down
we've got the
um staff are going to complete the
Privacy impact assessment I think that's
good Leslie range raise that
uh then we go to Six which is now has a
c
and um
so Mr T preps I could explain sex really
sex is the um I guess the mix that
depending on what you selected in four
could give you an option so really if
the project budget looks for
um towards a million dollars and we have
a current budget of 200 and you've
increased it by 250 under 4B
um to reach the target of a million
dollars um it would therefore the most
logical choice would be to go to 6B
um
however if you wanted to put more in you
could choose 6c
foreign
[Music]
so just to tidy this up I'm going to
move move uh that 6B please in favor all
right against that is completed that is
uh the remember those last from four
through to six uh recommendations to
council
it's been a long time coming wow it's a
long time
so basically everything's moved
cancel skills
okay it takes us on to the activities
report
okay uh Aaron's going to give us an
update
cool
thank you chair
um I will take um today's report as read
and open momentarily for any questions
um the key piece that I'd just like to
verbally add and there'll be some
information going out in a media release
this afternoon
um was that you'll be aware that we had
some work that is quite disruptive to
some parts of the city around storm
water crossing D Street up above Herbert
Street as part of those works we were
required to go quite deep under the road
and we've had an archaeological find
there where we found Timber that appears
to be a historic box drain
now what we have to do is work through
under an archaeological authority to
document that find because we we will
have to move it we can't go around it
which means we have to document it fully
before that happens so that's just going
to take some more time to work through
through that process and given that we
were coming fast into the Easter holiday
period we made the decision to actually
close that work up reopen the road for
the holiday period and then we'll have
to go back in and complete that work
after the break
yeah
right okay so any questions or comments
regarding the activities report or the
item Aaron is just Darren so just a a
quick query is there an explanation for
why
um Don Street
let's dug up again absolutely
um so you'll you'll I'm just looking at
Russell as to whether he wants to come
and speak to this one he can come and
speak if I get anything wrong
um but look essentially as per the
um section of the activity report on
Eskin Don Street
um the I guess main project is actually
complete but we're still working through
a defects period where we've identified
things on the project that um the teams
aren't happy with and we're going
through and rectifying at the moment so
that's why there's still some ongoing
work over the next few days to complete
that and Russell and his team do a more
detailed work over walk over tomorrow
um to check if there's anything
outstanding that we're not happy with
probably just to follow on a little bit
from here and and the ashfording that we
identified
um wasn't up to the standard that was
required and wouldn't last so
sufficiently so we've asked downers to
renew that replace that for us so who
zero was there
that's a quality issue that down as a
replacing at their cost thank you
Trish
um is this about any part of the
activities report yeah yeah so sorry
aged care housing you're going to hear
me a few times about this so I see that
we've got 90 people waiting now so the
four new homes that were um
opened and has that taken up some of the
slack or is is that still are they still
to come are they the tentative now no
those those new homes are only have not
actually started construction yet oh
sorry I thought they were finished no so
the the blessing that we had the other
day was our head of sight works
commencing oh thank you
sorry can I just speak further to that
though the other thing is that although
we have a program of upgrading the units
our initial focus is on
um essentially replacing our old housing
stocks so we don't actually expand with
more houses initially because we need to
actually replace that housing stock that
we've got I guess at the low oldest end
of our age profile
so basically you're keeping the same
stock but
um no we would actually be replacing it
right yeah
yeah so the numbers
creases it
uh in terms of making a significant ding
in that waiting list not
um not a significant ding on our current
investment profile no
thank you great yeah just on the
potholes
um I think a report come up a couple of
weeks ago we were only at seven now
we've got 30.
so are they developing that quickly that
we should be concerned are we just
getting better at identifying them or
what's happening with their reporting
um I'd need to check as to why there's
been a jump this week and I think this
month sorry and I can come back to you
um 30 sounds uh more realistic number
actually is what I would expect on a
network coming through from an RFS
perspective
okay Leslie thanks Mr chair I just
wanted to go back for a moment to the
housing situation and really look it's
just a comment but for me these the last
sentence there on um page 77 board books
um the turnover of tenancies remains
static we know basically that when our
tenants go under these properties they
go into them for life
we need more of them
that's the only comment I'll make
okay
I'm going to go to the mayor and then
Evelyn just as an update to that um when
we have our counselor only time shortly
I've got an update on
aged care facilities
okay Evelyn just because I'm a bit of um
I just really like the tap and the um
the information in the drips but that's
uh I want to comment on the city streets
and just say
um how
going down the street which I had to do
a lot last week
um the feedback that we're getting in
terms of particularly isk Street and how
it's looking and how people are
interacting with it and a lot of comment
about enjoying not having cars so we've
had this conversation before
um I think that it will be interesting
to see whether it feeds back when we go
out for consultation about people having
changed their minds about
the their preference for vehicles in
East Street because
particularly as it says in the report
the long summer days have meant that
people have really enjoyed that space
and not having to compete with vehicles
yeah I don't look I I don't think that a
choice of um
stopping cars in history there's
something we would consult on that's a
decision
obviously of council like it is and it's
one way that it I mean we've got the
ability to make a car free say for a set
afternoon or a Sunday afternoon whatever
but but obviously we've had information
before you know I keep going on about
the kobus mints uh report if you remove
vehicle movements however slow or one
way they may be you will
give a death blow to a street an X comes
from an international
um you know experts so look it's an
interesting point and I think we've got
the opportunity for lots of trials with
various things coming up of
um is that Russell we have the ability
to to uh obviously now with the health
and safety stuff it might be a bit
trickier
um stop it
guys make a comment yeah here we go
um look I think there's definitely uh
various different views within the
community and I would suggest to even
around the table around
um what
um esque Street might look like in a
perfect world
um what I would just draw everybody's
attention to is the fact that we have
still got Private Car parks that come
off esk Street
um and while that situation remains we
have to allow access through to those
car parks
I think part of what we're actually
talking about is
when we started the process or the
projects we had detailed uh guest
consultation with the retail groups in
there and part of that as part of the
design is what we initiated and showed
them what we're going to do with history
becoming more accessible
and I guess part of that was that the
cars would return and I think it's part
of the particle B is what is the
behavior of those cars once the return
is the key issue in my world
um yeah we've got a pro I think we've
got now got a place where the people
have claimed the space back and I might
have used it in the past where cars
might be welcome and I think that's part
of what we want to see is once we open
the street again and I guess that's once
that happens then the conversation I
guess can be had at any time about how
you use your street
but I think you need to test what you've
got now and how people will use it and
then look forward to that next decision
whenever that might be okay Alan and
then knobby
um yeah I just want to hike back to uh
sort of a problem sales that are made to
the retailers in history that they would
actually have access car access again
that's and to be feared of I've had to
put up with two years of you know very
um probably limited trading so I think
at the end of the day we need to go down
that path initially and whatever comes
from it probably almost be their choice
they might choose it they might find us
better not to but I think that's a
choice that they probably it's a drive
not us yeah
um Nobby yeah just to reinforce that
I've had some discussion with the
retailers there
um I think surveys that have been done
in the community would indicate that
most people want it closed permanently
but the retailers have had two Christmas
periods without without car accident and
some of them are strong we gave a
commitment that we would open it up in a
limited way so we need to honor that I
have suggested to the rate to the
retailers there that maybe we could look
at next summer having a trial period of
it being closed or alternatively it
could be open Monday to Friday but
closed on the weekends which is when you
get most of the foot tracker of people
coming in and we look at range of
potential options here and let them
decide with with the limited car parking
that's going to be there now whether it
actually brings back trade for them or
it's better to have a whole lot of foot
traffic and they're quite open to that
we just need to step through that over
winter and just have it the way we said
it we're going to have it and then and
then look to other options coming next
summer okay Darren thanks chair I agree
that there'll be a real lack of activity
in those winter months which could end
up making it look quite desolate if it's
um
if it's close to traffic but one of the
things that we need to bear in mind for
the retailers in East Street it it's not
the lack of road traffic that was as
much of a concern to them over that
period as it was the disrupted footpath
traffic which was even greater and the
look of a closed street so that's that's
what they've had to deal with and I
agree that you know we gave them an
assurance and and I really feel strongly
that we need to to live up to that and
maybe both parties re-examine things 12
months down the track once we've gone
through a year of the upgrade
okay we're all good
so
it's pretty straightforward that the uh
activities report be received we note
um the traffic signal outage because of
the lightning strike and the Milestone
completion of The Works in both isk and
Dom
um I'll have someone move that please
moved Evelyn seconded Grant I'll put
that allows in favor
against that is carried that brings us
to the end of the public session can I
have someone please move if we go into
public it's going to remove Grant
seconded Evelyn put their emotional
loads in favor
aye
carried
that we are now in
okay